Speaker 1: There is a very rapidly growing in
concern movement among the Republican Party
about how to get control of the party
back in advance of the 22 midterms and
certainly in advance of the 2024 Republican
presidential primary. Now you might be saying,
well, get control back from who, or you might
understand that the question is about getting
control back from Donald Trump, and there are
a number of interesting articles about this
that have come out over the last 24 hours.
One such article in The Washington Post
reports about clashes between Republican leaders
and the candidates that Trump has embraced,
and that these clashes have been playing off
playing out around the country. A chaotic sign
that Trump's once unchallenged hold on the party
and rank and file supporters is waning even by
degrees. And I think at this point, we have to
say Trump's control over the party is waning,
but only to a degree. In other words, we see
that the number of Republicans, the percentage
of Republicans that want Trump to run again
is lower, but it's still not low. It's still
above 50 percent of Republicans. At last check.
But interestingly, the Washington Post writes
the former president's power within the party
and his continued focus on personal grievances
is increasingly being questioned behind closed
doors at Republican gatherings, according to
interviews with more than a dozen prominent
Republicans in Washington and across the country,
including some Trump advisers. Not surprisingly,
many spoke on the condition of anonymity
because there remains significant fear of
attracting Trump's public wrath, also being
reported by Business Insider on the basis of The
Washington Post report. Republican leaders are
holding closed door meetings to question Trump's
power over, the party, report says. Now, I think
it's an important reminder, too, to tell you guys.
Questioning Trump's power is very different than
questioning Trump's questioning Trump ism, or the
sweeping authoritarian slide that the Republican
Party experienced under Trump. But we'll get
to that in a moment. Discontent with Trump
is growing among some Republican leaders. Senior
Republicans are questioning Trump's hold over the
party in meetings. Some Republicans reportedly
think Trump's fixation with election fraud
could cost them in elections. I think the
same thing, and I'm hoping that it happens,
and I think that there's there's there's a few
different things to talk about here. First of all,
it's sort of like six years too late in
the sense that we would be living not in a
different country, but on a different planet had
Republicans had these meetings previously. Now
they kind of did have these meetings early on in
the Republican primary and ultimately their voters
chose Trump anyway. How could the Republican Party
have done more to prevent Trump from having become
the nominee in 2016? Yes, they could have done
more, but it's possible that because you know,
the issue with the Republican electorate is
that it's a monster of their own creation. They
attacked education for decades. They abandoned
issues increasingly and focused on cultural issues
and talking points and this sort of thing. And
what that led to in 2016 was a monster that they
couldn't even control. Could they have turned the
ship around once it was summer of 2016? I don't
know. I don't know if they could have the the
other, you know, at the same time. The best time
to plant a tree is 20 years ago. The second best
time is today if the Republican Party is deciding
it wants out of Trump. OK, they didn't do it
six years ago, but they can start doing it now.
The bigger issue here is that even if it's
not in their best interests to have Trump
represent the party publicly, it doesn't mean
that they want to abandon the authoritarian,
non-thinking, reactionary slide that the party
experienced under Donald Trump. They're not
questioning Trump's authoritarianism. They're
not questioning Trump's disdain for media and
a free press. They're not. They're not
questioning any of that. The meetings
are about. Is it good for the face of the party
to be Trump doing rallies complaining about the
election he lost 15 months ago? It's about the
particular person that is out there speaking
prominently as the face of the Republican Party.
And in fact, I would say the opposite. They've
become enamored over. The last six years with this
kind of harebrained brand of authoritarianism,
and it's evident in that so many of them are now
talking about Ron DeSantis and falling in line
behind DeSantis. DeSantis is just as authoritarian
as Trump. He's more competent than Trump,
which could make him potentially more dangerous
and effective as well. So this is not a Republican
sort of reaction, saying we've we've got to get
away from this authoritarianism and get back to
issues. They're not saying that at all. They're
not saying, Wow, we've really tried to end even
the facade of democracy over the last couple.
They're all about all of that stuff. They are
just worried that Trump at the helm is not best
for them. From a strategic point of view, they
may be right about that. But they don't seem to be
concerned with the actual direction of the party.
They just want someone else at the head of the
party. So what effect will this have in November
of 2022? We just don't know yet. And Donald Trump
at this point, I don't think has more rallies
scheduled, but there has been talk about will
he go to Colorado in support of Lauren Boebert,
one of the most weaponized and dangerous results
of Trumpism in the House of Representatives?
What is Donald Trump going to be doing in general
between now and the November election? We will
talk a little bit later about one particular
thing that he's doing, which is backing Big Lie
supporters in positions of election
administration, which is exactly what
he said he would do. And he's doing it. We're
going to get back to that. But it could be a
very interesting matchup here between anti-Trump
Republicans and Trump going into the midterms.
What can we hope for as people on the left? Let's
hope it just messes them up and limits the degree
to which Republicans win in November, if at all.
And of course, we're going to try to work on the
if at all peace and avoid losing the
House and Senate, but remains to be seen.